hello everybody hope that you are good
daily videos are back and this time is
going to be consistent I needed to take
three or four weeks off some time off
and I explained on Twitter why but the
truth is that I felt a bit anxious and
and I struggled to accept a bit um my
current situation and is that in the
last three months I I was able to buy
two
apartments um then it's quite difficult
because I see you know where I come from
qu a humble place and my family my
friends around me so they still in the
same place but I'm not so sometimes it's
quite difficult to to accept the change
and I gu needed to take a few weeks off
to think about everything and come
stronger but anyway Bitcoin it seems
like it's taking also a little break
here because if you notice guys it's
dropped how much is this almost 18% 177%
down all right from the well new highs
because it made new highs it went all
the way to 74k pretty much now if you
follow me on X on Twitter um which I
guess most of you do last week I posted
two scenarios for Bitcoin when we were
in this area here and one of them was uh
the the main scenario the first scenario
was to change the structure because if
you notice here we have a low a high
then we have a lower low a lower high a
lower low a lower high and then okay at
this point here it was it the time to
make a new lower low and that would be
basically to attack this level here at
59k or instead to change the structure
and make a higher low okay and that is
basically what I was signaling here um I
was mainly supporting this scenario and
in yesterday soon the update we were
also paying attention to this idea now
how can you trade this well the first
thing is that if you notice the main let
me remove this the main resistance here
really is the 4our
is this purple line over here you can
see how it was also support back then
and if you scroll down you can see how
the uptrend comes from the level all
right and now it was getting tested as
resistance you can see here once twice
three times now in this third time it's
quite interesting because you can see
Bitcoin made an attempt to flip the
resistance into support but it missed
okay because you see this green candle
breaking above the 450 may but the next
candle this red candle is going to test
it it fails closes below it um then here
it kind of gets messy and it drops okay
now when you are looking for these flips
of support resistance sometimes you
don't get them in fact I think that it's
likely that we don't even get it here
okay I'm going to tell you what I think
what I see more likely but what I see
most likely guys in my opinion is that
this goes up straight from here and that
it doesn't come back to to test support
now we might he might do it it might
happen but I think that that's less
likely and I'm going to tell you why
because that's why everybody's waiting
for okay why do I use the 4 or 50 MAA
because that's what most Traders use the
50 and the 200 now the 200 really is the
same as the 50 because the 200 EMA in
the 1 hour time frame is the same exact
EMA as the 50 MAA in the 4H hour time
frame right that's what most people use
50 200 100 AMA and the 50 summons all of
them okay that's in different time
frames now if it comes to test this a
support which I don't think it will but
if it does then that could give us
another entry okay and you have to be
very careful that it doesn't happen the
same as it happened here okay you want
to see at least two candles testing it
as support not only one you want to see
two ideally three but you usually see
two and then you can see uptrend okay so
at least wait for two candles testing a
support that could be your entry because
if you notice here for example you only
happen once okay dark green candle
tested a support and the next one breaks
below it you need at least two candles I
always say this in in the course that by
the way you're going to have little
surprise at the end of the video but
anyway I still don't even think that's
going to happen I think that it's most
likely that this happens straight away I
don't know if it's going to go straight
to 72k but at least it's going to go to
69k okay and that could be this part of
the projection then maybe a 69k we got
the little ret that I'm talking about
here okay back to 67k but maybe by then
the 4 FMA can act as support but I see a
bit of continuation from here all the
way to 69k all right that's what I'm
more leing TOS so how can we trade this
well in my case yesterday I posted the
Su date and we we seeing this scandle
closing okay so in the analysis you can
see that I was pretty clear that price
was going to go up so I waited for this
candle here to close above the 4 or50
Main and then as soon as it closed I
open a long there and now to me I'm not
opening a new long here because I'm
already in the position so I'm not in a
r i will only open a new long and that
will be basically to DCA and to add
compound to add into my position if we
get a support here okay and I want to
see two candlesticks testing the 450 M
support if that happens then I'll open a
new long right now if I was not in this
long already I would open along here
with a small size and then if he comes
back to the 4 or 50 me and test a
support at least twice then I would
compound I would DCA in an open an long
all right but that's the way now what's
the inv validation to me clear literally
what I'm trading is the 4 or 50 all
right I'm I'm basically trading a a
resistance support flip so if we lose
the 4our 50 May if we close a 4our
candle back below the 50 in the 4 time
frames then I'm out of the position okay
um it's quite easy trade because right
now we are only I think 2% away not even
that one to 5% away from the 40 50 m so
if if I close a trade because the candle
closes here the risk is very low to me
okay only one to 5% in price value
difference all right so to me the risk
is very low and I'll tell you again if I
was not in a position I would open a
small long here with a small size and
then a bigger size if we get two test of
support of the 4H hour 50a okay and then
you will have two entries one here and
another one here and that could be
signaling that the for 50a that it was
resistance has now Become One support
and price can continue going up because
the whole narrative about price going up
is that the liquidity is to the upsite
and we going to have a look at this
right now let me take you to the book
let me tell you to high block Capital
I'm going to check that the liquidity is
really to the upside h capital
liquidation levels let me change the
setting Max liquidity cuz that's what
I'm used to let me check the Delta it's
a $6 billion worth of long liquidations
again as I always say take take this
amount with a pinch of sold because it's
not real is with the max liquidity
setting uh realistically it'll be
something like
this that it's like
220k okay $220,000 so but again I'm
going to change it into to Max liquidity
because that's what I'm used to still to
me $6 billion in this setting is not
much okay that's for your reference is
not much although it's pretty much the
same as we had here and then we saw a
retrace but usually this amount do
signal are reversal okay is still it
could happen but it wouldn't be linked
to this it's too small so we cannot say
okay because there are so many long
liquidations there is going to be a long
squeeze no that usually happens when in
this setting we have $30 billion $35
billion then yes we can talk about a
long squeeze or a short the squeeze but
when there is $6 billion if it reversals
is not going to be because of that
reason okay so nothing here is telling
me uh to favor downside or upside quite
quite neutral to be honest now the only
thing I'm noticing is that there is a
bubble here of liquidations at
63,000 but it's quite related there to
be honest so I'm not going to pay much
attention to it now if you go to the
liquidation hit maps and this is what
I'm finding more interesting
and we also talk about this on the sundd
yesterday is this area here at 69k look
at this okay what is the liquidity guys
look at this chart what are the yellow
bars pretty simple right
69,3 that's what all the liquidity is
well to be a specific between
68,500 and
70,500 but mainly that core of that
cluster of liquidations the main point
is going to be at 69,3 so that's what
I'm favoring price to go next okay 69 to
3K of course from there maybe we start
to see this area 70k 70 to 5K getting
jellow getting brighter because you know
I mean when price goes up there's always
going to be some traders that going to
try to catch the top they're going to
open the position in the opposite side
that happens so that could favor 70 to
5K to get in this case a jellow okay a
jellow bar of liquidity so for now 69.3k
that's where the liquidity is now let's
go and check the order book welcome to
the order book guys most of you know
what this is by now because I show it in
many of my videos but for those that
don't know what you are seeing in the in
the screen right now this chart is the
it's a chart that keeps all the orders
of the main exchanges binance bybit all
right and the pr that the bar goes at a
different price level it means that
there is more liquidity in that level so
for example right now we are at
67,900 and you can see that right above
the current price there is different
bars showing up it goes from red orange
now also yellow is look it's going to
turn now there is no bar okay those are
sell orders now it's not only sell limit
orders it could also be take profits
from a long position because that's also
a sell order in the order book okay or a
stop loss from a short position that's
also going to show in the order book so
it's not only sell limit orders for
example at
68,000 we all can see that there is a
red bar of liquidity that it's quite
serious is Stu there and it's not
moving that is not
necessarily a cell wall is not
necessarily many Traders placing sell
limit orders at the price level and when
price gets there price is going to
reverse it's not necessarily that
because it could also be liquidations it
could be a stop loss from short
positions it could be take from long
positions we don't know what it is the
only thing that we know from looking at
this chart is that there is a lot of
liquidity at that level and the chart
moves well Bitcoin and any asset that is
trading with a lot of liquidity is
basically going to move towards those
liquidity zones all right so by looking
at this chart where do we see the
liquidity at well we see it at 68,000
right so that is telling us that the
order book is favoring the liquidity
going to the upsite and we can use this
tool as a Confluence for the direction
of price all right so we have the order
B saying 68k upside we have high block
Capital saying that liquidations are at
69k upside and we also have the chart
telling us that there is a potential
resistance support flip with the 4 R50
and with all of that I come to the
conclusion that I must favor higher
prices this is how I trade first I need
to find the direction once I find the
direction or the target then I need to
look for my entries and I've explained
them already all right so that's pretty
much everything that I'm seeing this
video I don't want to make it too long
and before you close the video I want to
leave you with a little outro so thank
you so much for watching guys and I'll
see you
soon
yeah